une grande ligne du dispositif voté par
le Sénat depuis plusieurs années quant à
l'âge d'annulation de la décote il est
et restera à 67 ans c'est important pour
les nombreuses femmes qui doivent aller
jusqu'à cet âge pour ne pas avoir de
décote sur leur pension grâce à cela
notre système sera à l'équilibre en 2030
alors je suis bien consciente de ce que
cela signifie pour beaucoup de nos
compatriotes c'est pourquoi nous avons
construit un projet de justice celles et
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler plus
tôt pourront partir plus tôt
les carrières des femmes souvent
incomplètes ou hachée seront mieux
prises en compte la pénibilité des
métiers sera mieux reconnue nous
continuerons à tenir compte des plus
fragiles un départ à 62 ans sera
toujours possible pour les personnes en
invalidité en incapacité ou en
inaptitude au total 4 français sur 10
souvent les plus fragiles les plus
modestes celles et ceux qui ont des
métiers difficiles pourront partir avant
64 ans j'ajoute que la justice c'est
aussi fermer la plupart des régimes
spéciaux car le même métier doit donner
la même retraite et ce n'est pas tout
notre projet sera porteur de progrès
social
conformé un engagement du Président de
la République nous allons augmenter la
retraite minimale pour une carrière
complète au niveau du SMIC à 85% du SMIC
soit une hausse de 100 euros par mois et
ce dès cette année nous avons aussi
entendu l'appel de plusieurs groupes
politiques et d'organisation syndicales
et patronales et je vous confirme que
l'augmentation de la retraite minimale
concernera bien les retraités actuels au
total près de 2 millions de Français
verront leur pension revalorisée dès
cette année ce sont d'abord des femmes
ce sont d'abord des commerçants et des
artisans qui ont travaillé toute leur
vie c'est un progrès social majeur
enfin nous voulons rendre aux salariés
proches de la retraite toutes leurs
places en entreprise avec davantage de
transparence sur les politiques des
employeurs avec l'assouplissement de la
retraite progressive et avec un cumulent
retraite plus avantageux alors monsieur
le Président Roquier aujourd'hui mon
ambition avec mon gouvernement avec tous
ceux qui veulent préserver notre système
de retraite par répartition c'est de
convaincre autour de ce projet c'est de
chercher à l'améliorer avec le Parlement
et je sais que le Sénat il prendra toute
sa part c'est de construire ensemble un
système juste équilibré et porteur de
progrès social je vous remercie merci
le président hockey merci Madame prairie
océan il n'y aura pas la grande classe 3
il n'y aura sûrement pas les questions
préalables dont le débat ira son terme
et nous appelons notre groupe il prendra
toute sa part et permettez-moi un petit
rappel historique au début du siècle au
début du règne Louis XVI
interpellé comme contrôleur général des
finances parce qu'il est difficile il a
proposé les mesures audacieuses
ambitieuses certaines suppressions de
privilèges et il a eu cette formule la
réforme plutôt que la révolution
quelques années après il y a pas eu
d'informes quelques années après il y a
eu la Révolution et bien j'espère que
cette réforme de retraite n'amènera pas
la Révolution
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Raymonde pour ses manches pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez présenté hier une
réforme des retraites qui allonge de
nouveaux de deux ans l'âge de départ à
la retraite vous avez balayé nos
solutions alternatives pour combler un
déficit que vous dramatisez fiamment et
qui n'aurait jamais dû être un problème
si le fond de réserve des retraites
n'avait pas été siphonné mais alimentée
comme prévu vous vous gardez de
présenter bilan de la Contre-Réforme de
2010 que vous vous apprêtez à copier
soit la baisse tendancielle du montant
des pensions et de la durée de vie à la
retraite selon l'adresse en 2016 la
réforme de 2010 avait déjà fait perdre
presque un an de durée de retraite à la
génération 80 en cumulant toutes les
réformes depuis 2010 plusieurs
générations perdront jusqu'à 20 mois de
durée de la retraite non seulement ces
réformes ont affectées au travail la
grande partie des gains d'espérance de
vie mais votre réforme va empiéter sur
les années de vie à la retraite en bonne
santé et il n'y a rien de plus
inégalitaire quand selon l'Inde l'écart
de vie en bonne santé de 10 ans entre
catégories socio-professionnelles votre
réforme s'attaque au droit au repos de
tous les travailleurs mais quand une
plus dur sur les classes populaires les
ouvriers les employés comme avaient
allongé le sas de précarité des ni en
emploi ni en retraite pour une partie au
chômage ou au RSA dont vous réduisez
dans le même temps les droits l'attaque
contre le monde du le travail et la
protection sociale est frontale et
systémique et dévoile ce que recouvre le
credo du travail plus pour perdre sa vie
à la gagner et détruire l'habitabilité
de notre retraite de notre planète
pardon monsieur le ministre pensez-vous
qu’après une crise sanitaire qui a
interrogé la place et le sens du travail
alors des urgences il est responsable
d'imposer une réplique de la
Contre-Réforme inégalitaire de 2010 et
ce contre une très large majorité des
Français et des représentants syndicaux
pour vous répondre la parole des taux
ministres du travail fait l'emploi de
l'insertion Monsieur Olivier du socle
vous avez la parole merci aussi monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs
finalement au travers de votre question
vous nous dites est-ce qu'il faut faire
une réforme des retraites la réponse est
oui elle est positive pour trois raisons
trois raisons que vous retrouverez dans
le rapport du Conseil d'orientation des
retraites que dit ce rapport ce rapport
dit d'abord que le système est
déficitaire déficitaire dès 2023 avec
une perte d'un milliard 8 déficitaires
en 2027 avec un déficit de 12,5
milliards d'euros déficitaire en 2030
avec presque 15 milliards d'euros puis
20 milliards d'euros par an en 2035 25
milliards d'euros en 2040 et l'enjeu de
cette réforme c'est aussi de préserver
un système de répartition de le
préserver avec d'autant plus d'attention
que les chiffres que je donne à
l'instant sont des chiffres qui sont
prévus par le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites dans l'hypothèse où nous
aurions atteint le emploi c'est-à-dire
une hypothèse à laquelle nous
participons que nous souhaitons mais qui
reste une très optimiste et si le canon
plein n'était pas au rendez-vous les
chips seraient encore plus dégradés et
le système serait encore plus en danger
une première règle de solidarité c'est
de permettre aux génération qui viennent
de conserver un système de répartition
et de le faire sans être étouffé par la
dette ni à sauver par les impôts la
deuxième raison pour laquelle il faut
faire cette réforme c'est parce que si
nous la faisons pas là aussi c'est le
rapport du corps qui le dit le niveau de
vie des retraités va baisser et je ne
suis pas sûr madame la sénatrice que
vous souhaitiez retrouver la situation
des années 70 quand les retraités
étaient les pauvres du pays alors même
que notre système para répartition a
permis aux retraité justement d'avoir un
niveau de vie qui soit identique à celui
de l'ensemble des Français et puis il y
a une troisième raison c'est une raison
démographique que la chef du
gouvernement a exposé à la fin des
années 70 nous étions trois actifs à
cotiser pour un retraité aujourd'hui
nous sommes un tout petit peu plus de
1,5 actifs pour un retraité c'est la
démonstration ça ne tient pas puisque ça
ne tient pas il faut réparer réparer
avec des mesures d'accompagnement sur la
disponibilité sur les carrières longues
pour protéger les plus fragiles réparer
dans le débat et je dis devant le Sénat
parce que la responsable de votre partie
la responsable des vers au niveau
national à happy de ses vœux que
l'Assemblée nationale se transforme en
ZAD ça n'est pas notre conception de la
démocratie et je souhaite comment ici
nous puissions mener un débat apaisé
[Applaudissements]
quelques secondes
quelques secondes monsieur oui
la réponse vous sera donnée le 19 par la
mobilisation des français auprès des
organisations syndicales et des parties
de la gauche et écologiste
la parole est à notre collègue Franck
venonville pour le groupe Les
Indépendants Républiques et territoires
mon cher collègue
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en raison
des hausses exorbitantes des coûts de
l'énergie dans mon département de la
Meuse ce sont déjà sept boulangers qui
ont cessé leur activité
pour faire face à l'augmentation des
prix des matières premières certains
boulangers ont déjà dû réévaluer leur
prix de vente une nouvelle augmentation
tarifaire serait aujourd'hui
inenvisageable mais pour grand nombre
d'entre eux la situation est aujourd'hui
intenable face à cela différentes
mesures à destination des boulangers ont
été annoncées le 4 janvier dernier je ne
reviendrai pas sur les conditions
d'éligibilité néanmoins concernant le
bouclier tarifaire 80% des boulangeries
ne peuvent aujourd'hui prétendre car
elle dépasse le seuil de 36 kW avec
l'utilisation des fours des chambres
froides des pétrins et des vitrines
certes l'amortisseur électricité devrait
pouvoir s'activer mais nos boulangers
nous alertent régulièrement sur le prix
de 180 euros le mégawatts qui selon eux
restent trop pénalisant et encore pas
assez protecteur les conditions des
lisibilité ne sont pas suffisamment
adaptées aux difficultés rencontré par
la profession et les démarches et les
démarches sont perçues comme trop
complexes pour que les dispositifs
soient accessibles et rapidement
applicables il faut s'appuyer sur les le
réseau local et notamment faciliter la
compréhension de ces dispositifs les
accompagnements annoncés vont certes
dans le bon sens mais force est de
constater qu'ils sont insuffisants au
regard de l'intensité des difficultés de
la profession monsieur le ministre
est-ce que le gouvernement entend
proposé un dispositif plus protecteur
pour les TPE les plus impactés il me
semble important et urgent d'envisager
un déplafonnement de la puissance de 36
kW pour étendre ainsi le bénéfice du
bouclier tarifaire ce serait là une
mesure simple et bien comprise
pour vous répondre la parole est comme
ils disent de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté Monsieur Bruno Le
Maire merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs sénateurs monsieur
le sénateur
vous avez aujourd'hui à peu près 2,1
million de très petites entreprises
moins de 10 salariés moins de 2 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires vous
l'avez rappelé 1,5 millions d'entre
elles sont protégés par des tarifs
régulés parce qu'elles ont une puissance
électrique inférieure à 36 kg a donc
elle elles sont totalement couvertes par
le bouclier tarifaire et n'auront pas
d'augmentation leur facture
d'électricité de plus de 15%. je
rappelle qu'il n'y a aucun autre pays
européen qui propose cela à ces très
petites entreprises
graissent 600 000 très petites
entreprises alors on aurait pu
effectivement étendre le trv600 mille
entreprises le coût était de 3 milliards
d'euros et j'aurais certainement
bénéficié à quelques milliers de
boulangers mais il serait si bénéficier
des centaines de milliers d'autres
entreprises qui n'en ont pas
nécessairement besoin alors qu'il faut
aussi protéger des PME aussi protéger
les entreprises de taille intermédiaires
industrielles exposées à la concurrence
internationale c'est pour ça qu'avec la
première ministre on fait un choix
différent mais très protecteur nous
avons obtenu des fournisseurs que la
facture moyenne puisse pas dépasser les
280 euros le mégawattheure en moyenne
sur l'année 2023 je rappelle que
beaucoup de boulangers vous avez raison
de le souligner sont pris en tenaille
entre l'augmentation du prix de la
farine l'augmentation du prix des
matières premières et des coûts
d'électricité qui pouvaient atteindre
700 800000 euros le mégawattheure là ils
ont la garantie que leurs factures sera
plafonnée à 280 euros en moyenne
mégawattheure c'est une protection
majeure et nécessaire pour les
boulangers si certains ont encore des
difficultés ils peuvent bénéficier du
report de charge de l'amortisseur sur
l'électricité et du guichet sur le
pourront venir réclamer les subventions
si j'en ai encore besoin qui peuvent
amortir la facture de 40%. donc je crois
très sincèrement que nous avons pris
avec Elisabeth borne toutes les
dispositions nécessaires pour protéger
une profession à laquelle nous sommes
profondément attachés les boulangers et
protégeant priorité toutes les très
petites entreprises de France bien
entendu ma porte et celle d'Olivia
Grégoire reste toujours ouverte à la
discussion merci la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue
Jean-François Husson pour le groupe les
républicains
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre Bruno Le Maire finalement
acteur économique acte 2 monsieur le
ministre j'entends votre brevet
d'autosatisfaction mais il y a quelques
instants encore j'avais un chef
d'entreprise au téléphone qui regroupe
les demandes de nombreux acteurs
économiques les boulangers ça a été dit
vous l'avez dit il en manque et c'est
grave mais également l'ensemble des
acteurs économiques qui aujourd'hui ne
comprennent pas
l'absence de vision stratégique du
gouvernement pour venir en aide et en
soutien quand vous parlez de 280 euros
c'est grosso modo jusqu'à
350% d'augmentation par rapport à des
prix récents quand et comment les
acteurs économiques peuvent-ils tous
subir cette concurrence le risque et
vous le savez c'est d'avoir un mur de
cessation d'activité par de faillite BPI
France près 70 000 euros monsieur le
ministre considérez-vous aujourd'hui
avoir pris toutes les mesures pour
répondre aux besoins de l'ensemble des
entreprises qui font vivre la maison
France
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Économie des Finances
Bruno Le Maire
monsieur le rapport en général on n'est
jamais certain d'avoir pris toutes les
mesures
c'est pas la première crise que j'ai à
gérer nous avons géré avec le
gouvernement la crise du covid avec
votre soutien votre compréhension nous
avons mis en place un quoi qu'il en
coûte parce que la richesse française
était effondrée la production cet été
fondée et il y avait un risque de
faillite par vague de successives et
d'une explosion du chômage de masse et
on m'avait averti de ce risque là il ne
s'est rien passé nous avons protégé le
monde économique protégé les
entrepreneurs protégés les entreprises
évitez un chômage de masse nous avons
géré avec efficacité la crise du covid
face à la crise de l'inflation le quoi
qu'il en coûte n'est pas la bonne
solution le quoi qu'il en coûte c'est
jeter de l'essence sur l'incendie et ne
pas se débarrasser de l'inflation vous
nous reprochez de pas avoir de vision
stratégique je pense que nous avons une
vision stratégique qui est de faire
baisser l'inflation dans le courant de
l'année 2023 et ne rien faire qui puisse
prolonger l'inflation dans les années
qui viennent le quoiqu'il en coûte
aujourd'hui sans doute que ça servirait
immédiatement les grandes entreprises
mais l'ensemble de la population
française se verrait exposer au maintien
d'un niveau très élevé d'inflation avec
tous les dommages que ça représente pour
les entreprises et tous les dommages que
ça représente pour les ménages donc nous
avons choisi une voie qui est plus
difficile mais j'ai toujours considéré
que la voix difficile et d'être en
général la meilleure celle qui consiste
à cibler les entreprises qui en ont le
plus besoin les très petits entreprises
c'est ici et tout à l'heure et qui n'ont
pas les reins suffisamment solides pour
réagir elles ont des tarifs
préférentiels elles ont une protection
elles ont un guichet qui était
maintenues au 1er janvier elles ont le
report des charges elles ont dans chaque
département un numéro d'appel 1.06 d'un
conseiller qui peut les aider elles ont
la possibilité d'étaler les prêts
garantis si elles le souhaitent reste
les PME avec lesquels nous sommes en
discussion nous voulons protéger notre
outil industriel protéger nos PME
protéger nos entreprises de taille
intermédiaire qui elles sont exposées à
la concurrence internationale et ne
peuvent pas augmenter leur prix parce
que sinon elles perdront leur marché là
aussi bon le nécessaire notre vision
stratégique c'est protection immédiate
de ceux qui en ont besoin faire baisser
l'inflation sur le moyen terme pour se
débarrasser de cette plaie et sur le
long terme continuer une politique de
l'offre qui favorise la compétitivité de
nos entreprises je sais vous nous
rejoindrez sur ce point-là
monsieur
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre vous avez il y a
peu expliqué que vous souhaitiez parler
aux fournisseurs d'énergie bah écoutez
vous en avez un qui est tout trouvé sous
la main et que vous contrôlez
entièrement il s'appelle EDF donc
mettez-vous au travail et rapidement
pour apporter des solutions je rappelle
je rappelle que pour EDF nous payons ici
les choix funestes menés depuis 10 ans
pour arrêter la production d'électricité
nucléaire on en paye très charmant le
prix
monsieur le ministre je l'ai dit nous
avons besoin d'avoir une vision
stratégique en domaine énergétique pour
travailler sur les énergies
renouvelables pour travailler sur
l'autonomie énergétique et pour
travailler sur notre souveraineté
énergétique notamment dans le
renouvelable et dans nucléaire tout ça
doit en plus améliorer le sol de notre
balance commerciale et enfin Monsieur le
Ministre TPE PME ETI grandes entreprises
les entreprises de France ont besoin
d'un soutien adapté mais encore faut-il
travailler en constance avec ses
représentants d'entreprises il compte
sur vous la France a besoin d'un État
fort à ses côtés merci
la parole est notre collègue Catherine
Morin deci pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues comme mes deux prédécesseurs
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Économie et porte sur la situation des
boulangers en France
il y a quelques semaines j'aurais tirer
votre attention sur ce fait était
annoncé l'inscription de la baguette
française au patrimoine immatériel du
l'UNESCO mettant en valeur la filière de
la boulangerie c'est traditions et ses
savoir-faire
serait-elle alors menacée en effet dans
nos départements en ce moment les mers
nous alerte sur les graves difficultés
rencontrées par les boulangers qui
doivent faire face et que ça a été
rappelé à une explosion de leur facture
d'électricité alors monsieur le ministre
vous avez bien exposé les mesures
annoncées par le gouvernement le mois
dernier la possibilité de recourir à
l'amortisseur électricité le report du
paiement des impôts et des cotisations
sociales l'étalement du paiement des
factures d'énergie les fournisseurs vous
l'avez aussi rappelé ont d'ailleurs
accepté que l'ensemble des si on signe
un contrat d'électricité au cours du
second semestre 2022 ne paie plus de
papa plus de 280 euros par mégawatt
heure en moyenne sur l'année 2023 alors
tout cela est très bien mais les
dispositifs sont complexes a été rappelé
et surtout ça va se mettre en oeuvre
qu'à la fin du mois or très
immédiatement les boulangers nous
alertent sur leur problème ils font
immédiatement face à une hausse
considérable du coût des matières
premières c'est plus de 30% avec
percutés sur leur charge et ils peuvent
pas augmenter perpétuellement les prix
sous peine de voir leurs clientèle BC
donc l'heure est grave monsieur le
ministre et nombre de boulangers sont au
bord de la faillite du dépôt de de bilan
donc c'est dramatique pour eux mais ça
l'est aussi pour nos territoires mes
chers collègues la boulangerie et le
commerce le plus élémentaires en zone
rurale celui qui maintient la vie dans
dans nos villages donc que comptez-vous
faire monsieur le ministre
particulièrement peut-être en lien avec
les grandes régions qui disposent de la
compétence économique et qui œuvrent
aussi à trouver des solutions je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre les paroles est au
ministre
de l'Économie des Finances Monsieur le
Maire
merci à Monsieur le Président Madame
Monsieur Patrice Catherine dossier vous
permettrait juste une toute petite
dégression pour répondre à Monsieur
Husson qui me demande
qui me demande de me mettre au travail
je vous rassure je suis au travail et je
n'ai pas un très grand goût pour la
feignantise
madame Morin de saillie pour être tout à
fait concret et répondre à nos amis
boulanger aujourd'hui la seule chose que
nous demandons à nos amis boulanger
c'est d'aller soit sur leur site dédié
soit sur un pot.gouv.fr de se déclarer
comme très petites entreprises parce
qu'il se trouve que EDF je rassure aussi
Monsieur Jean-François Husson je reçois
EDF au minimum toutes les semaines avec
Agnès panier renacher et avec Olivia
Grégoire donc nous sommes en contact
très régulier il faut qu'il se déclare
comme très petite entreprise parce que
les fournisseurs d'énergie ne le savent
pas et il faut qu'il déclare puisque
nous venons de modifier le formulaire
qu'il souhaite bénéficier du tarif
garanti à 280 euros en moyenne donc tous
les contrats qu'ils ont pu signer à 500
600000 euros le mégawattheure ils sont
résiliés et automatiquement ils auront
droit ce tarif à 280 euros c'est une
protection massive et pour ceux pour
lesquelles ça ne suffit pas je le
rappelle guichet unique amortisseur qui
réduit de 20% l'augmentation de la
facture et décalage du paiement des
charges lorsque c'est vraiment
nécessaire donc je crois que le maximum
a été fait reste maintenant et je veux
en dire un mot les petites et moyennes
entreprises les entreprises de taille
intermédiaire qui elle sont confrontées
à la même augmentation des tarifs et qui
sont exposés à la concurrence
internationale je prends juste un
exemple très concret j'étais à
Charleville-Mézières il y a quelques
jours j'ai vu une entreprise
industrielle qui fait des plaques en
aluminium pour refroidir les véhicules
électriques et bien son fournisseur et
son acheteur qui est en l'occurrence un
constructeur automobile allemand lui dit
vous ne pouvez pas augmenter les prix
sinon je me fournis ailleurs comment
est-ce que je fais cette entreprise qui
est confrontée à un acheteur qui dit je
ne bouge pas mes prix et à une
augmentation des prix de l'électricité
il faut qu'on leur apporte des solutions
on y travaille aujourd'hui nous ne
voulons pas affaiblir notre base
industrielle
de cette crise énergétique
merci la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Marie-Claude royasse pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'aurais pu
vous adresser monsieur le ministre ma
question par la poste mais il aurait
fallu que je prenne mon mal en patience
que je fasse le choix du thème revers et
son délai désormais de J + 3 ou alors
que je paie une lettre I une illette
rouge que je devrais scanner avant de
l'importer sur un site internet afin
qu'un agent des postes l'imprime et la
transporte jusque chez vous cet agent
aurait même accès à ma correspondance
aussi confidentielle soit elle le thème
rouge n'est plus et vous entendez faire
passer cela comme une lettre à la poste
expression vouée à la désuétude selon
vous la mesure effective depuis le 1er
janvier est un pas de plus vers la
désagrégation du service public qui doit
assurer l'égalité et l'équité et il n'y
a pas de plan B cette dématérialisation
synonyme de déshumanisation
ignore la fracture numérique qui
concerne selon l'Insee 13 millions de
Français vont-ils devenir des
sous-citoyens en conséquence vous lancez
dans 68 communes expérimentations de la
réduction de fréquences du passage du
facteur derrière la tournée du facteur
monsieur le ministre l'accueil à un
guichet ce sont des liens humains qui se
tissent bien souvent avec les plus
fragiles et les plus défavorisés or nous
savons que tout ce qui coupe les liens
sociaux abîment la démocratie c'est ce
que nous a dit à nouveau ce que nous dit
à nouveau cette mesure c'est que la
machine exclure tourne à plein régime
monsieur le ministre quand allez-vous
stopper cette opération de casse du
service public essentiel pour la
population quand le gouvernement va-t-il
entendre qu'un service public n'est pas
voué à être rentable
pour vous répondre la parole et
communiquer en charge de la transition
et des télécommunications monsieur
barreau vous devez la parole monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice varias
vous interroger le gouvernement sur
l'évolution de la politique de courrier
du groupe La Poste à laquelle nous
sommes très attentifs et vigilant avec
la première ministre de l'économie et
des finances et il ne nous a pas échappé
qu'effectivement les les nouvelles les
évolutions les évolutions nouvelles ont
suscité de la part de nos concitoyens
certaines questions et inquiétudes
légitimes permettez-moi de vous rappeler
les deux raisons pour lesquelles la
Poste fait évoluer aujourd'hui son offre
de courrier la première c'est que les
usages de nos concitoyens ont évolué là
où ils envoyaient 45 lettres
prioritaires en 2010 il n'en voit que 5
en moyenne en 2021 ce qui ne veut
évidemment pas dire qu'il ne faut pas en
envoyer et que par ailleurs les
évolutions prévues par le groupe de la
Poste permettrait selon les calculs du
groupe d'économiser 60 000 tonnes de CO2
par an soit 25% de la consommation du
groupe et par conséquent grâce notamment
à l'arrêt du transport aérien dans
l'Hexagone ceci étant dit si vous voulez
bien me laisser
terminer mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs quelques éléments qui je
l'espère seront de nature à vous
rassurer d'abord les timbres qui ont été
les timbres rouges qui ont été achetés
avant la fin de l'année sont évidemment
fonctionnels d'autre part la présence du
facteur 6 jours sur 7 n'est pas remise
en question tout
usagé pourra se faire conduire au bureau
de poste à tout moment par un facteur
c'est un engagement du groupe La Poste
et enfin le la lettre service plus qui
arrive après deux jours et la lettre
verte qui arrive après trois jours
seront évidemment disponibles enfin
c'est l'histoire de l'expérimentation
que vous avez évoqué elle ne remet en
aucun cas en question la présence tous
les jours du facteur sur les territoires
et pour toutes les activités de
distribution de la poste je vous
remercie
tiens avec mon groupe c'est qu'après
l'hôpital le rail l'énergie la
disparition du timbre rouge monsieur le
ministre symbolise le démantèlement de
nos services publics patrimoine de ce
qui n'en n'ont pas avec l'attaque contre
notre système de retraite c'est
l'ensemble du dispositif de solidarité
qui est mis en cause sous les injections
de Bruxelles l'exaspération des Français
est à son paroxysme en ce début d'année
allez-vous enfin les entendre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Didier
Rambaud pour le groupe du Rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendant merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
nous changeons d'années mais les défis
liés à l'actualité eux persistent en ce
début d'année où les cérémonies de voeux
rythme nos soirées nos semaines nous
sommes tous ici interpellés par les élus
locaux les professionnelles des TPE des
PME et nos concitoyens sur la crise
énergétique actuelle interpellé à de
nombreuses reprises sur les conséquences
mais aussi sur la réponse politique et
économique du gouvernement être
entrepreneur requiert du sang-froid et
beaucoup d'abnégation la période
actuelle en exige encore davantage en
effet cela a été dit par mes collègues
précédemment à l'image des boulangers de
notre pays parfois rares survivants du
commerce de proximité dans nos
territoires et particulièrement impacté
par l'inflation des coûts liés à
l'énergie de nombreux professionnels des
TPE des PME n'arrive pas toujours à
identifier le niveau d'aide dont ils
peuvent bénéficier et ne disposent pas
toujours du temps nécessaire pour
décrypter les différents dispositifs mis
en place par le gouvernement des
dispositifs inédits pertinents et adapté
qui gagneront à être rappelé
collectivement au plus grand nombre
alors face à la désinformation parfois
la démagogie et aux approximations pour
que tout artisan boulanger de notre pays
puissent bénéficier des aides
considérables en vigueur et continuer de
travailler avec davantage d'optimistes
je souhaite profiter de ces séances
madame la ministre pour vous interroger
sur le travail qui a été mené pour les
Françaises et les Français au-delà de
leur modalités ces dispositifs sont-ils
efficaces sont-ils suffisants les
réponses apportées au boulanger symboles
des professionnels impactés ont-elles
été entendues et enfin concrètement que
chacune et chacun puisse bénéficier des
aides comment l'étape entend t-il
accompagner les professionnels pour
faciliter leur démarche merci
pour vous répondre la parole est la
madame Olivia Grégoire
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Député le sénateur Rambo
nous nous adaptons à la situation une
situation qui est compliquée pour nos
artisans et pour nos boulangers en
particulier
deux trois éléments 12 milliards d'euros
mobilisés au moment où on se parle 12
milliards d'euros pour aider nos PME nos
TPE plus vous êtes petit plus vous êtes
exposé plus vous êtes protégé vous êtes
un boulanger 80% ils sont les chiffres
de la Confédération des boulangers
dépasse les 36 qui le veulent Ampère ça
a été mentionné plafond du TRV d'un
ventes vous avez un prix garanti de 280
euros le mégawattheure vous n'avez
qu'une chose à faire une chose à faire
remplir une case je suis une TPE sur
l'attestation qui se trouvera à
différents endroits pour être sûr que
vous la trouviez en tant que boulanger
sur votre espace professionnel sur votre
fournisseur en ligne là où vous recevez
vos factures mais aussi dès maintenant
sur le site impôts gouv.fr sur la page
d'accueil l'attestation est disponible
on peut la télécharger on coche une
cache une TPE je veux bénéficier des
conditions tarifaires et ce sera mise en
oeuvre dès les prochaines semaines sur
votre facture si ça ne pas l'amortisseur
vient c'est très pratique là c'est
pareil rien à faire vous allez cocher la
case TPE rien à faire la facture tiendra
on prendra en compte 15 à 20% de baisse
directement sur la facture si vous êtes
une TPE mais aussi une PME ça suffit pas
un beau point gouv.fr et là je me
permets là aussi de répondre à Monsieur
Husson les aides sur un beau point
gouver.fr
qui a posé la question
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tapez juste six mois que les aides sont
sur un pot.gouv.fr il me semble
important de rappeler que les aides je
passe mon temps à ça expliquer juste que
sur les aides d'Octobre Novembre
Décembre on peut en disposer dès le 16
janvier en allant sur un pot.gouv.fr une
dernière chose quand on est en artisan
on a confiance en Celui qui déclare
votre TVA tous les mois on travaille
avec son expert-comptable je travaille
avec les experts-comptables qui sont
aussi aux côtés de nos artisans en cas
de doute appelez les nous travaillons
ensemble pour mieux accompagner au
niveau des artisans boulangers je vous
remercie
la parole est à l'autre collègue Monique
Rubin pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
monsieur le ministre hier soir en
écoutant les annonces de madame la
Première ministre j'ai pensé à des amis
des connaissances Isabelle Jean-Marc
Philippe la première travaille dans
l'agroalimentaire depuis 40 ans et elle
devait prendre sa retraite à 62 ans elle
devra travailler un an et trois mois de
plus le deuxième il est charpentier il
entre dans le dispositif carrière longue
mais qui sera repoussé et donc il devra
travailler plusieurs mois de plus le
troisième veine de perdre son emploi à
60 ans peu d'espoir d'en retrouver un et
une durée d'indemnisation du chômage que
vous venez généreusement de réduire et
la perspective d'un meilleur revenu
produit par la retraite qui s'éloigne
vous allez faire payer votre réforme
idéologique par ceux qui travaillent
depuis longtemps déjà qui cotise depuis
longtemps déjà et qui ont les métiers
les plus difficiles et les moins bien
rémunérés et par les précaires et dans
le même temps vous ne demandez aucune
contrepartie aux employeurs vous refusez
obstinément de mobiliser les gains
parfois faramineux engrangé par depuis
quelques mois alors monsieur le ministre
vous qui ne cessez de mettre en avant la
valeur travail pourquoi maltraitez-vous
à ce point les travailleurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame la madame la sénatrice
pardonnez-moi la réforme est nécessaire
j'ai évoqué la raison pour laquelle il
fallait la faire pour sauver le système
par répartition j'ai aussi dit qu'il
fallait faire avec le plus de justice
possible il y a deux éléments qui
répondent très précisément à votre
question le premier élément c'est que
nous avons dans le cadre de la
concertation que j'ai menée depuis
plusieurs mois travailler avec
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux tous
les partenaires sociaux tous les
syndicats toutes les organisations
patronales et avec les groupes
politiques nous avons consulté et nous
avons nous avons abouti nous avons
abouti sur un certain nombre de
convergence ça n'est pas les désaccord
sur l'âge mais il y a des convergences
sur la question de la pénibilité nous
modifions contre le compte de personnel
de prévention avec l'ensemble des 6
critères pour en faciliter l'acquisition
des points nous créons la possibilité
d'un véritable congé de reconversion
nous faisons en sorte de mieux protéger
ceux qui travaillent de nuit ou en
équipe postée nous allons retravailler
sur la question des ports de charge des
postures pénibles
délibérations pour faire en sorte que
les accords de prévention soit là et
c'est un milliard d'euros sur cinq ans
qui seront consacrés au financement de
la prévention tout en renforçant la
possibilité de partir de manière
anticipée dans le cas d'un suivi médical
renforcé sur les carrières longues vous
l'avez évoqué nous maintenons évidemment
et bien évidemment le départ à 58 ans
pour tous ceux qui ont cotisé 5
trimestres avant 16 ans nous maintenons
le dispositif existant celui qui permet
de partir avec deux ans d'avance pour
ceux qui ont cotisé 5 trimestres avant
20 ans et nous créons un nouveau
dispositif qui va s'appliquer très
certainement à ceux que vous avez évoqué
pour que ceux qui ont cotisés 5
trimestres avant 18 ans et je pense tout
particulièrement apprentis que ceci
puisse partir avec quatre ans d'avance
et à 60 ans sans qu'il y ait de bouger
d'âge pour ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler le plus tôt la vérité madame
la sénatrice elle est peut-être sur deux
points le premier c'est que les exemples
que vous avez cités les amis que vous
avez auquel vous avez pensé je souhaite
pour vous que ce soit des amis
imaginaires parce que le principal
bouger le principal décalage de la rage
de départ c'est la hausse de la durée de
cotisations vous avez voté en 2013 et la
deuxième chose que je vais vous dire
c'est quand vous écoutant et je j'ai en
tête les propos du responsable du parti
socialiste qui s'est converti à la
doctrine de Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous avez
ainsi perdu le sens de la raison et la
responsabilité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre qu'il est doux à
mes oreilles de vous de me faire des
remarques à moi sur ce qu'a fait ma
famille et politique et ce que nous
avons voté quand ça vient de vous
monsieur le ministre vous et moi savons
très bien
j'ai quelques souvenirs monsieur le
ministre dans le département des Landes
avec un de mes grands anciens qui
s'appelait Henri Emmanuelli et que vous
aimiez beaucoup à l'époque de vous
appréciez beaucoup à l'époque voilà donc
fallait pas me tenter monsieur le
ministre le corps le corps dit que la
part des retraites dans le pays B c'est
14 % que ça ne bouge pas et que donc le
système n'est pas en danger les critères
de pénibilité que vous venez de donner
c'est vous qui les avez enlevés en 2018
quand vous êtes arrivés au gouvernement
et vous pouvez le traduire comme vous
voulez monsieur le ministre mais cette
réforme vous la faites uniquement payer
par les salariés et par les plus
modestes des salariés et j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure des réactions quand je
citais mes amis qui ne sont pas
imaginaires croyez-le j'ai entendu oh oh
mais quand on a travaillé 42 ans et
qu'on demande de travailler un an de
plus c'est un an de trop
la parole est maintenant madame la
Présidente Sophie prima pour le groupe
les républicain
merci monsieur le Président
ma question s'adressait à Madame pagnès
Agnès panière une haché depuis un an
notre pays traverse une crise
énergétique effroyable le gouvernement
allume bien sûr des contrefeux nous
avons entendu quelques explications
bouclier tarifaire amortisseur filet de
sécurité 24 milliards d'euros en 2022 43
milliards en 2023 l'échec comme mode de
gouvernement sont très dangereux vous le
savez financé par de la dette mal
calibrée complexe dans leur exécution
insuffisant toujours insuffisant à
défaut de solutions structurelles vous
arrosez le sable avec de l'eau la
solution structurelle elle est
européenne car nous sommes aujourd'hui
prisonniers de l'architecture européenne
du prix d'électricité Vion électricité
gaz charbon madame la ministre l'état de
guerre a pulvérisé le marché énergétique
la disparition du gaz russe la
déséquilibrer profondément et
probablement définitivement il faut donc
tirer les conséquences de cet état de
fait et abolir immédiatement les
mécanismes de concurrence qui génèrent
l'architecture du prix de conseils
européens en Conseil européen nous ne
voyons rien venir nous ne voyons rien
bouger à défaut pour la France d'avoir
le poids désormais suffisant en Europe
pour faire bouger les choses demander
des dérogations immédiates d'autres
l'ont fait y compris dans des pays où
l'interoparabilité est forte madame la
ministre c'est urgent on ne peut plus
attendre les prochains conseils
européens notre économie ne le
supportera pas merci de nous dire votre
action
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre
de la transition énergétique madame la
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la Présidente prima vous l'avez
dit nous avons d'abord agi au service
des ménages au service des entreprises
et au service des collectivités locales
en prenant le plus rapidement possible
des mesures qui font qu'aujourd'hui la
France
offre ou permet à ces différentes
catégories d'avoir le prix de
l'électricité le plus bas d'Europe je
veux le rappeler car ce n'est pas une
politique du chèque c'est une politique
est assis aussi sur une contribution sur
la rente inframmerginale c'est-à-dire le
surplus de bénéfice que crée cette
situation particulière de crise
énergétique que vous avez souligné sur
plus de bénéfices chez nos producteurs
d'électricité donc c'est aussi une
approche où nous savons gérer le budget
de l'État à de bonnes fins avec des
aides proportionnées les ménages et les
TPE étant les mieux protégés j'ai obtenu
cela a été rappelé avec Bruno Le Maire
et OL déjà Grégoire ce plafonnement du
prix de l'électricité des contrats à 280
euros du mégawatt-heure vous soulignez
très justement que l'action doit se
passer aussi au niveau européen vous
avez raison de le souligner parce que ce
que nous subissons c'est d'abord un acte
de guerre 40% de l'approvisionnement en
Europe de gaz et d'origine russe 22% de
la production d'électricité européenne
est basée sur le gaz ça c'est une
réalité physique dont il faut prendre
compte vous savez également on en a
parlé encore ce matin en commission
développement durable et à faire
économique pour la présentation du
projet de loi nucléaire que la situation
de notre part que nucléaire nous rend
aujourd'hui dépendant de
l'approvisionnement en électricité de la
part d'autres pays européens et donc
c'est une réalité également physique
dont il faut prendre compte alors nous
avons agi en européen tout ce qui nous
permet aujourd'hui de passer cette crise
cet hiver avec une baisse des prix
d'électricité certes pas satisfaisante
mais nettement inférieure au début de
l'année grâce au stockage de gaz grâce
aux flat plafonnement du prix du gaz et
du aux décisions que nous avons pris au
niveau européen il a Commission
présentera au premier trimestre grâce à
l'action du gouvernement une proposition
sur le marché d'évolution du marché
d'électricité dans le sens que vous
appelez de vos vœux je vous remercie
madame la Présidente
[Applaudissements]
j'ai encore quelques instants je rêve
d'un pays fort en Europe madame la
ministre nous étions un pays fort en
Europe capable d'imposer des décisions à
l'Europe or là il y a urgence il y a une
grande urgence car à la fin du premier
trimestre quand l'Europe aura pris ses
décisions peut-être nous aurons dépensé
dans le budget de l'état des milliards
d'euros au travers de chèques et nous
n'aurons toujours pas de solutions
structurelle donc je rêve d'un pays fort
capable de faire bouger l'Europe et de
prendre des décisions au bénéfice de
notre pays
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Victoria Lurel pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur un
collègue
contenu de la gravité du sujet et de son
caractère interministériel ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
j'ai associé mes collègues Catherine
qu'on connaît victoire jasmin elle porte
sur le non-lieu prononcée le 2 janvier
dernier dans l'enquête sous la
contamination et la pollution au
chlordicône je respecte les décisions de
justice mais à l'espèce personne ne
pourrait s'en satisfaire cette décision
est une indéniable déni un déni pouvant
allumer des brasiers puisqu'il y aurait
Nick coupable ni responsable bien
qu'attendu cette décision ajoute au
scandale d'État un scandale judiciaire
madame la Première ministre au-delà des
actions menées par tous les
gouvernements et par le vôtre des plans
mise en place et de la reconnaissance de
la carence fautive des pouvoirs publics
je considère pour autant que l'État
reste co-responsable majeur de cette
tragédie et en reste encore comptable 46
ans après les premières alertes 16 ans
après la première plainte vous ne pouvez
rester indifférente alors je formule ici
quatre demandes au-delà des suites que
les partis civils ne manquons pas
détendentifs contentez-vous tout faire
dans le respect du droit pour que le
parquet ouvre ce dossier êtes-vous prêt
à créer un fonds d'indemnisation pour
toutes les victimes êtes-vous prêtes à
faire pour les victimes du chloredicates
qui a été fait pour les victimes de
l'amiante êtes-vous prêtes à renforcer
l'action de l'État dans la recherche
fondamentale dans la dépollution des
eaux et des sols j'attends de vous une
réponse humaine débarrassée de toutes
veines polémique
pour vous répondre la parole est
Jean-François caraco mini délégué en
charge des Outre-mer monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire hier à l'Assemblée
nationale je constate comme vous la
décision prise librement par les
autorités judiciaires un membre du
gouvernement ne peut qu'en prendre acte
j'ai bien lu les attendus de
l'ordonnance il pointe une
responsabilité collective dans ce
scandale sanitaire
mais vous l'avez dit cela la Moinerie en
rien la responsabilité de l'État face à
ce scandale reconnu d'ailleurs pour la
première fois par le Président de la
République en 2018 et nous devons
continuer d'avancer sur ce chemin
notre priorité à tous et protéger la
santé de nos concitoyens des délaisseurs
économiques impactés de renforcer la
recherche
avec Gérald Darmanin avec le ministre de
la Santé le gouvernement s'est engagé et
s'engage encore à répondre à ces enjeux
plusieurs avancées fortes j'insiste là
dessus ont déjà été obtenus la
reconnaissance du cancer de la prostate
comme maladie professionnelle ouvrant
droit indemnisation
analyse gratuit du taux de chordicône
dans le sang analysez sol ou encore
conséquent travaux de recherche engagés
pour la dépollution des sols le colloque
scientifique et les rencontres du
terrain de terrain du mois de décembre
ont été l'occasion de porter à la
connaissance ces nombreuses avancées
mais ils ont montré aussi qu'il avait
encore beaucoup à faire dans ce cadre
je note vos propositions qu'il nous faut
étudier avec attention et volonté
d'aboutir si l'ordonnance est le droit
et la chose jugée cela nous empêchera
pas de continuer à avancer je me rends
en Martinique dès demain en partie pour
cela la cordonnatrice du plan chlore
déconne m'accompagnera à cet effet je
vous remercie
Dieu
madame la Première ministre que vous
n'ayez pas saisi d'occasion ici pour
marquer votre considération aux
populations de Martinique et de
Guadeloupe frappait de sidération et
déjà marqué dans leur chair sur le
ministre vous me faites une réponse que
je connais et qui est celle d'un
communiqué vous savez fort bien que tous
les gouvernements engagé des actions et
qu'aujourd'hui
la les plans cordées connaît notamment
le 4 est insuffisant il est sous doté et
il est sous-financé 2,4 millions pour la
recherche fondamentale par an ce n'est
pas suffisant il faudrait au moins 5
10,8 millions par an alors que nous
mettions 12 millions en 2010 avec
Monsieur Sarkozy et 13 millions en 2016
il faut conclure suffisant monsieur le
Président je demande que le gouvernement
nous fasse bénéficier du préjudice
d'anxiété à l'instar de l'amiante merci
la parole est à notre collègue
Alain bidon pour le groupe les
républicains merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre de la Santé le
président de la République a dit
clairement on a insisté de reconstruire
notre système de santé pour l'adapter et
satisfaire les attentes des
professionnels comme des patients mais
pour y parvenir une réforme globale de
l'organisation de ses soins de leur mode
de financement et des synergies à mettre
en œuvre est nécessaire pour restituer
une attractivité perdue et profondé un
système innovant performant viable et
humains hélas les orientations proposées
posent davantage de questions que de
solutions efficaces et urgentes le
financement est absent totalement de ce
discours présidentiel sortir de la T2A
par exemple dès le prochain bel effet 16
pour lui substituer une rémunération
basée sur des objectifs de santé
publique négociées à l'échelle du
territoire fondé sur un critère
populationnel non défini ça laisse
perplexe comment imaginer que l'objectif
déficience puisse être atteint tout en
rendant la part de financement à
l'activité minoritaire c'est bel et bien
à notre avis sonner le glas de l'hôpital
quant au 6000 postes d'assistants
médicaux supplémentaires c'est pendant 3
ans l'assurance maladie qui payera quid
de la pré et comment l'assurance maladie
perd-t-elle quand on sait que les 4000
assistants déjà mises en place coûtent à
celle-ci 160 millions d'euros les
propositions concernant la médecine de
ville ne sont pas à la hauteur et ne
permettent pas d'enrayer la crise de
vocation ni la propagation des déserts
médicaux monsieur le ministre comment
entendez-vous répondre avec précision et
concrètement aux attentes des soignants
hospitaliers libéraux sans procéder à
une refondation complète des modes de
financement entre les différents
sénateurs que les différents financeurs
pardon que sont la sécurité sociale de
pas d'une part et les mutuelles d'autre
part
pour vous répondre la parole commise de
la santé de la prévention chez Brown
Michel Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Milon
le 6 janvier dernier le président de la
République a tenu un discours devant les
soignants traçant un nouveau cap une
feuille de route pour la refondation
complète de notre système de santé avec
un diagnosticide mais surtout un
changement dans l'analyse et la méthode
vous le savez passer d'un système qui a
été construit autour de l'offre de soins
forcément concurrentiel vers un système
pour plus répondre aux besoins de santé
de nos concitoyens beaucoup a déjà été
faits que ce soit dans le Ségur que ce
soit entre autres la suppression du
numérique clausus mais nous devons aller
effectivement plus loin plus vite pour
répondre aux défis qui sont devant nous
et qui d'ailleurs concernent l'ensemble
des pays européens et d'une façon
générale l'ensemble des pays
industrialisés il y a des axes forts
régler le problème à l'échelle de chaque
territoire sortir de cette logique
concurrentielle pour travailler en
complémentarité ville hôpital clinique
médecin paramédicaux médicaux
administratif et puis retrouver des
collectifs à l'échelle humaine comme en
particulier l'échelle des services pour
l'hôpital redonner du temps médical de
redonner du temps de soin est un enjeu
majeur car comme la préciser le
président ce n'est pas tout de suite que
nous aurons les médecins que nous
attendons après la suppression du
numerus clausus alors comment faire
laisser les soignants faire ce pourquoi
ils sont formés c'est-à-dire le soin
développer des assistants médicaux en
l'aidant à cette installation les
maisons de santé plus professionnelle à
l'hôpital en intégrant les logisticiens
les administratifs au plus près du
service il faut utiliser les mieux les
compétences de chacun la plus-value de
chaque professionnel au sein d'équipe
traitante autour du médecin traitant ou
au sein des services de l'hôpital
résonner territoire par territoire
réformer vous l'avez dit le financement
de notre système de santé en particulier
en sortant de la T2A qui n'est qu'un
financement quel acte en s'ouvrant vers
un financement certes toujours à l'acte
pour certains mais qui répond aux
besoins de santé de la population et qui
est un financement à la qualité à
l'efficience nous l'avons fait déjà pour
les services d'urgence nous allons
continuer à le faire pour l'ensemble des
médecins généralistes sont déjà dans cet
axe ce sont des engagements forts envers
les soignants envers nos concitoyens
pour leur santé et soyez assurés que
nous allons aider très rapidement
puisque les échéances sont courtes et
que je serai totalement motivé et
mobilisé pour se faire cela Monsieur
[Applaudissements]
oui merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
monsieur le Président les propositions
que vous venez de nous faire sont des
propositions que nous faisons depuis des
années on a déjà entendu sous différents
ministres depuis madame Marisol Touraine
en passant par un amusant et par
Monsieur Véran il y a finalement rien de
nouveau à ce niveau-là il y a donc
aucune vision alternative qui est
structure la réflexion du gouvernement
moi je vous en donner quelques unes qui
vous permettez dans le système de santé
qui se construisent il y a les soins
primaires il y a le panais de son
régulier il y a la mise en réseau
obligatoire il y a un pilotage fort et
décentralisé on n'a jamais parlé de
décentralisation dans le pilotage des
ARS et c'est bien dommage une réflexion
globale sur le financement et non pas
simplement une réflexion telle que vous
la donnée mais une réflexion sur
l'ensemble du financement en particulier
sur les dépenses merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Pierre
Antoine Lévy pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues la question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre délégué chargé du
numérique monsieur le ministre comme ma
collègue parillasse tout à l'heure et
beaucoup de françaises et beaucoup de
Français je me pose cette question où va
le service public postale aujourd'hui en
effet depuis le 1er janvier les timbre
rouge réservés aux en bois de l'aide
prioritaire ne sont plus commercialisées
la modernité selon la poste c'est soit
disant là il est trop rouge il faudrait
donc se connecter en ligne pour rédiger
ou scanner une lettre qui sera ensuite
retranscrite puis imprimée par une agent
de la poste avant d'être envoyé pourquoi
faire simple quand on peut faire
compliqué oui la confidentialité dans
des écrits dans ce nouveau process cette
prétendue révolution pose surtout le
problème de l'accès de tous au service
public postale l'égalité est portant
l'un des grands principes de la notion
de service public dans notre pays la
réalité c'est qu'en pratique
l'électronisme touche près de 14
millions de concitoyens surtout en
milieu rural
alors certes ils pourront toujours aller
dans un bureau de poste pour envoyer
leur lettre prioritaire si bien sûr il y
en a un ici n'est pas fermé mais comment
expliquer aux citoyen qui choisit les
présents utilisent un automate une borne
pour faire envoyer leur lettre après
avoir scanner des documents de plus en
pratique les agents de 6 bureaux de
poste ne pourront pas toujours aider ces
personnes lorsque l'influence est très
importante elles seront laissées seules
devant l'automate cette réforme donne
comme une impression de rajouter de la
complexité à quelque chose qui était à
la base fort simple en fait nous
apprenons également qu'à partir du mois
de mars le courrier ne serait plus
distribué tous les jours mais un jour
sur deux puis pourquoi pas un jour sur
trois cette réforme est à
l'expérimentation dans certains
départements mais elle risque d'être
généralisée à toute la France
mais le risque est grand que cette
réforme désorganise le service postal et
qu'à l'aboutit signe fini à la
suppression de nombreux emplois alors ma
question est simple monsieur le ministre
et vous n'avez pas répondu tout à
l'heure allez-vous blesser continuer à
se déliter ce service public historique
il est urgent d'agir avant que nous
devenions tous tombés je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole et
communiste déléguée en charge
télécommunications monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Lévy je ne
reviendrai pas sur les constats qui ont
conduit le groupe La Poste à prendre ses
décisions mais je veux réaffirmer une
nouvelle fois le profond attachement du
gouvernement à l'univers civil à
l'universalité du service postal qui est
d'ailleurs inscrite dans la loi je veux
redire une nouvelle fois que la présence
du facteur est maintenue 6 jours sur 7
que tout
usagé rencontrant des difficultés ayant
la nécessité d'effectuer un envoi
prioritaire pourra se faire accompagner
par un facteur au bureau de poste et
qu'en fin les services liés à la lettre
service plus qui arrive deux jours après
à destination et la lettre verte qui
arrive trois jours après à destination
seront évidemment assurés s'agissant de
l'expérimentation que vous citez elle
vise à tester de nouvelles modalités de
distribution dans les 68 communes que
vous évoquiez mais en aucun cas elle ne
remet en question la présence tous les
jours du facteur sur l'ensemble du
territoire en revanche monsieur le
sénateur je ne pourrai laisser dire sur
d'autres bancs peut-être que ce
gouvernement ne se désintéresse de la
fracture territoriale avec 2600 maisons
françaises réparties sur l'ensemble du
territoire avec action cœur de ville
avec petite ville de demain avec
territoire d'industrie avec 4000
conseillers numériques qui ont
accompagné un million 300000 personnes
depuis un an sur le territoire national
c'est ce gouvernement qui a mis fin à
une quinzaine d'années d'aveuglement sur
l'aggravation de la fracture
territoriale et je crois que vous en
conviendrez soyez monsieur le sénateur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
convaincus de l'attachement de ce
gouvernement à la réservation de la
lutte contre la fracture territoriale
quelques secondes
monsieur le ministre désolé mais je ne
suis pas absolument pas convaincu je
peux vous confirmer et ici tous mes
collègues sénateurs le confirmeront la
Poste ne distribue pas six jours sur 7
mais certaines fois 4 jours ou 5 jours
et que cette expérimentation inquiète
énormément de français dans tous les
territoires donc je vous le redis
qu'allez-vous faire pour éviter le
délitement du service public
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Story
pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères à la fin du mois de décembre
les autorités en place à Ouagadougou on
te demande des sous d'obscurs prétextes
le débat de léonbassadeur de France ce
nouvel épisode des tensions qui émanent
une relation avec le Burkina Faso n'est
pas sans rappeler le scénario qui s'est
déjà produit au Mali et en Centre
Afrique illustre surtout le fait que
dans cette partie de l'Afrique où elle a
pourtant tant œuvré la France est
récemment devenue indésirable malgré
l'engagement de nos militaires contre le
terrorisme islamiste et le sacrifice de
53 d'entre eux malgré le niveau
considérable de l'aide au développement
déployé dans cette zone prioritaire
jamais la France n'y a été tant
critiquée étant rejeté donc il s'est
concitoyens expatriés ont subissent
malheureusement les effets mais plus
largement c'est bien dans l'ensemble du
continent africain que l'influence
économique politique diplomatique ou
même culturelle de notre pays ne cesse
de s'éroder ces parts de marché ont
ainsi fondu la moitié par rapport au
début des années 2000 et ce recul ne
fait que s'accélérer depuis l'année
dernière
la France n'est plus le premier
partenaire commercial d'aucun des pays
du Maghreb dans de nombreux pays la
langue française voit son influence
reculée et est maintenant concurrencé
par l'Anglais jusque dans les programmes
scolaires voir comme au Rwanda en tant
que langue officielle et si la France
reste le premier pays de destination des
étudiants africains sa capacité à tirer
pour les former sur son sol les futurs
élites et désormais en recul par rapport
à d'autres destinations avec ces
formidables atouts aussi bien humain que
naturel l'Afrique est un nom pas douter
un continent d'avenir mais cet avenir si
nous ne sommes pas capables de remettre
à plat l'ensemble des politiques que
nous y menons ces dernières années
risquent fort de s'écrire sans la France
depuis 2017 la situation s'est dégradée
et nous envoyons aujourd'hui les
conséquences alors madame la ministre
quelle stratégie le gouvernement tant il
mettre en œuvre au cours de ce
quinquennat pour enfin enrayer le déclin
général de française en Afrique
pour vous répondre la parole de la
ministre de l'Europe des Affaires
étrangères madame Colonna
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur story disons les choses en
Afrique comme ailleurs les manipulations
de l'information ne cesse de prendre de
l'ampleur et dans plusieurs pays la
France est visée par des campagnes des
campagnes qui n'ont rien de spontané on
le sait et nous le savons bien puisque
la secrétaire d'État aux partenariat
internationaux étaient hier encore au
Burkina Faso je la remercie de cette
visite elle est allée portée un message
qui était clair comme vous l'avez vu
face à cela nous devons agir mais nous
devons agir avec les moyens les outils
d'une démocratie et c'est ce que nous
faisons nous opérons un triple
changement j'ai demandé à mon ministère
de le mettre en oeuvre car oui nous
devons changer l'Afrique change et nous
devons également changer un changement
de contenu il s'agit de mieux expliquer
la réalité de nos partenariats ou
l'innovation les entreprises les
artistes les jeunes ont une place
centrale
changer c'est aussi se placer au soutien
de ceux qui journalisent ce fight
checker lutte contre la désinformation
changement de support ensuite il s'agit
pour nous d'être partout présent
beaucoup plus qu'auparavant partout
présent ou se forment les opinions
africaines y compris sur les réseaux
sociaux et permettre ainsi de vous
adresser un public plus jeune et enfin
changement d'échelle par l'accroissement
du volume de ce que nous produisons et
par la mobilisation du réseau
diplomatique est en prise avec les
réalités et les interlocuteurs locaux
tout ceci monsieur sénateur en
complément de nos relations humaines de
nos relations économiques qui persistent
qui change elles aussi l'enjeu est
considérable vous l'avez dit soyez
assuré que notre mobilisation les tout
autant si je suis arrivé avec quelques
instants de retard après le début de
cette séance je vous
présente mes excuses c'est que le
Président de la République recevait le
président des Comores et après cette
session je me rendrai à 10 à Beba avec
ma collègue allemande siège de l'Union
africain donc nous sommes actifs vous le
voyez je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant de notre
collègue Emilienne punirol pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste avec
Nassim monsieur le Président chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de la Santé de la
prévention la pénurie du médicament
sujet quasiment inexistant dans les
années 2010 devient un problème majeur
de sécurité et de souveraineté nationale
avec une aggravation des tensions depuis
la crise covid en 2023 lors du bandons
encore et toujours de l'un des la Chine
en particulier à qui nous achetons plus
de 80% des matières premières moins de
40% des médicaments sont fabriqués en
Europe pourtant dans le monde d'après
tout serait différent le président
Macron nous l'avait assuré la France
allait retrouver sa souveraineté
industrielle or les pénuries et les
tensions n'ont jamais été aussi fortes
en particulier sur les médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur et à
l'hôpital certains anticancéreux ou
immunosuppresseurs utilisent dans les
grèves du rhum par exemple manque
obligeant à choisir les patients pouvant
en bénéficier c'est une perte de chance
inadmissible pour les patients et
d'autres pénuries de médicaments aussi
courant que
oblige les pharmaciens à délivrer les
boîtes au compte-goutte alors Monsieur
le Ministre ma question est simple quel
est votre stratégie pour retrouver une
production en France ou pour le moins en
Europe
on va répondre la parole commise de la
santé de la prévention chevron
sur le Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs madame la sénatrice pour
mirolles je partage en partie votre
diagnostic mais je vais préciser un
petit peu les choses deux années de
crise sanitaire celle que nous avons
traversé en bouleversé complètement
notre consommation et entraîner à la clé
des difficultés d'anticipation des
volumes de production par les
industriels parallèlement à cela nous
constatons une forte reprise de la
consommation plus 13% par exemple en
France pour le paracétamol et également
dans des pays comme la Chine on le voit
bien c'est une situation qui ne concerne
pas que la France même pas que l'Europe
qui est une situation aujourd'hui
mondiale
notre système d'alerte nous permet
d'anticiper
autant que faire ce peu cette situation
grâce à un suivi de nos stocks
stratégiques mais je comprends bien sûr
et je vois l'inquiétude des gens qui
vont chercher les médicaments dans les
pharmacies tout en sachant la
mobilisation remarquable des pharmaciens
qui se mobilisent très fort pour trouver
les différents produits alors face à ce
diagnostic nous avons mis en place un
traitement nous avons Agito nous
interdisons les exportations à
l'étranger ce qui est en France reste en
France nous contingentons les stocks
nous adaptons pour avoir une répartition
homogène sur l'ensemble du territoire
nous échangeons avec les laboratoires
concernés pour prioriser certaines
formes de médicaments nous avons
autorisé la reproduction d'amoxicilline
par des laboratoires en France
nous adaptons la dispensation en
officine vous l'avez dit au juste besoin
des patients et nous travaillons avec
les professionnels sur les alternatives
thérapeutiques ça c'est des actions
immédiates nous allons plus loin en
reconstruisant notre souverain
industrielle mais ça va pas se refaire
en 5 minutes bien évidemment la France
investit massivement depuis plus d'un an
dans le cadre de France relance dans le
cadre de France 2030 des projets de
relocalisation très concrets sont en
train de voir le jour je pense au
paracétamol dans le projet C15 également
des masques des gants nitriles et puis à
Arras une usine pour la production de
médicaments dérivés du sang à partir de
plasma sanguin donc oui nous sommes dans
l'axe pour regagner notre souveraineté
en France au sein de l'Europe sur les
médicaments et en attendant nous faisons
le maximum pour que tous les Français
puissent avoir les traitements qui leur
sont nécessaires je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre je crois qu'il ne
faut pas se cacher derrière la crise et
les mesures que vous indiquez ils ne
sont en fait que les gestion de la
pénurie notre groupe propose pourtant
depuis plusieurs années dans les
discussions du PLFSS plusieurs solutions
et en particulier le renforcement de nos
capacités de production publique avec
les pharmacies centrales des hôpitaux ou
des armées ou la possibilité réquisition
d'entreprise et il faut surtout un plan
concerté de réindustrialisation en
France et en Europe les industriels
arguent d'un prix trop bas des
médicaments alors mettons en carte sur
table sur la fixation des prix qui est
aujourd'hui protégée par le secret des
affaires pour qu'il tienne compte des
aides publiques directes ou indirectes
dont il bénéficie la loi du marché et le
libéralisme peuvent gouverner notre
politique en matière de produits de
santé rembourser une ciné par la
Sécurité Sociale donc l'argent de tous
les contribuables pour construire une
véritable indépendance de la production
il faut une politique publique forte et
volontariste
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Christine Lavarde pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
du CES de Las Vegas vient de se clôturer
elle a laissé une par large aux
automobiles et à cette obligation le PDG
de ses lentilles Carlos Tavares a lancé
une nouvelle charge contre le niveau du
prix extrêmement bas des véhicules
chinois zéro émission qui met en péril
l'industrie européenne et cette
industrie pour le seul territoire
national c'est 210 000 emplois directs
auxquels il convient d'ajouter tous les
emplois indirects si j'en crois les
objectifs affichés par trois
constructeurs chinois pour les citer
gélier sec et griswall à E3 ils
envisagent d'importer un million de
véhicules sur les territoires européens
d'ici trois ans ils sont déjà en train
de construire le système de distribution
qui leur permettra d'atteindre cet
objectif alors certes sur le territoire
national les véhicules électriques
progressent plus que 46%
d'immatriculation en 2021 mais 80% de
ces véhicules sont importés et la presse
ne s'y trompe pas elle écrit d'ailleurs
le loup chinois est la bergerie en effet
la Chine c'est 50% de la valeur totale
d'un véhicule électrique c'est 75% de la
chaîne de valeur des batteries c'est 90%
des moteurs électriques produits dans le
monde et face à tout ça l'industrie
européenne est en très grande difficulté
elle ne parvient même plus à pénétrer le
marché chinois alors dans cette bataille
qui vient de commencer monsieur le
ministre quels sont nos armes avez-vous
choisi une guerre de position et donc de
continuer à subir les assos chinois ou
entendez-vous sortir de notre tranchée
et lancer une guerre de mouvement
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'économie et les finances
de la souveraineté industrielle Monsieur
Bruno Le Maire merci monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice d'avoir
merci pour votre excellente question me
réponds va être très clair nous sommes
favorables à une guerre de mouvement
avec de l'offensive et de la défensive
l'offensive s'être capable d'avoir au
21ème siècle une industrie automobile
électrique en France en Europe aussi
performante que celle que nous avons eu
sur le véhicule thermique au 20e siècle
je rappelle que c'est ce gouvernement
cette majorité qui a pris l'initiative
il y a maintenant auprès de 4 ans de
mettre sur pied une filière de batterie
électrique pour être moins dépendant de
la Chine nous allons ouvrir les deux
premières usines de batterie électrique
nous avons un objectif à 2030 de
produire environ 100 à 120 GW de
puissance électrique avec des batteries
produite en France sur les territoires
français vous savez vous avez travaillé
dessus que nous voulons rouvrir une
usine de lithium que nous voulons
diversifier nos approvisionnements nous
voulons également être indépendant en
matière de semi-conducteur qui sont
absolument indispensables sur le
véhicules électriques nous avons obtenu
l'investissement de Global fun rise sur
le site d'estemicro pour développer
massivement la production de
semi-conducteur qui servir aussi au
véhicules électriques donc l'objectif
est très clair être indépendant en
matière de production de véhicules
électriques ça c'est l'offensive les
matériaux les batteries les
semi-conducteurs et au bout du compte
comme la annoncé d'ailleurs stellantis
la production de ces véhicules
électriques sur le sol français et
croyez moi l'offensive sera très
volontaire première question que vous
soulevez qui est majeure et moi je vous
invite à participer aux travaux nous
avons lancé sur le projet de loi de
l'industrialisation verte jusqu'où
allons-nous dans le volet défensif
est-ce que par exemple nous réservons
les aides 7000 euros aujourd'hui pour un
vécu électrique à des véhicules produits
et assemblés uniquement en France et en
Europe la question est légitime après
tout d'autres le font faut-il renforcer
le mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières pour dire ça ne concerne pas
uniquement le ciment l'acier l'aluminium
mais ça peut aussi concerner des vrais
bien manufacturés par exemple des
automobiles je n'ai pas la réponse à ces
questions mais le défensif est capable
de poser ces questions de discuter avec
tous les sénateurs les sénatrices que je
souhaiteraient dans le cadre du projet
de loi industrialisation ouverte nous
sommes avec la première ministre à
mettre sur pied des volets défensifs
pour être autonome sur le véhicule
électrique
certaines des questions que vous venez
de poser pourtant vous avez donné la
réponse en octobre dernier devant la
plateforme automobile vous avez dit
qu'il fallait pas le se laisser envahir
et qu'il fallait réserver les aides à
des véhicules produits en Europe c'est
ce que vous a proposé le Sénat nous
avons ici adopté un amendement qui
venait de diminuer de 500 millions ces
aides qui sont versées essentiellement
aux industriels chinois vous l'avez
retiré c'était pourtant une mesure de
souveraineté et qui venait aussi à
améliorer notre déficit budgétaire et
vous ne l'avez pas gardé c'est bien
dommage merci
la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Pierre bogel pour le gros plaid
républicain
merci monsieur le Président de ma
question s'adresse à Madame la Ministre
Olivia Grégoire la filière equide
représente plus de 11 milliards d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires 20000 entreprises
et 66000 emplois directs cette filière
irrigue notre territoire elle est
présente dans 91% des cantons avec plus
d'un million de chevaux l'équitation
c'est aussi 2 millions de pratiquants
dont 700 000 licenciés et donc la
troisième fédération olympique et le
premier sport féminin le monde du cheval
s'est enfin plus de 827 millions de
recettes directes pour l'État à travers
les paris hippiques et 295 millions
d'euros à travers la TVA
ministre quand et par quel véhicule
législatif le gouvernement donnera la
filière équine un cadre fiscal
garantissant sa pérennité et son
développement et le respect de la parole
donnée quand vous répondre la parole est
à Madame Olivia Grégoire ministre
délégué en charge les petits du
moyen-entreprise du commerce et de
l'artisanat je le sénateur voguel merci
pour votre question qui me permet de
souligner et remercier d'ailleurs la
constance de la position du gouvernement
sur la question du cadre fiscal de la
filière équine ça vous a été rappelé je
crois lors des débats sur le projet loi
de finance pour 2023 la cohérence du
système fiscale repose sur une
application du taux réduit de la TVA de
5,5 qui est comme vous le savez bien
réservé aux biens et services de
première nécessité évidemment des
denrées alimentaires mais aussi des
appareils les équipements pour les
personnes handicapées ou encore
le logement et la nourriture dans les
maisons de retraite dans cet optique
généraliser le bénéfice de taux réduit
TVA 5 5 à toutes les ventes d'équidées
ainsi qu'aux prestations liées à ces
animaux ne serait pas justifié ça
poserait aussi des difficultés en termes
d'équité à l'égard d'autres disciplines
éducatives sportives aussi digne
d'intérêt gouvernement est attentif à la
filière équestre il apporte son soutien
significatif à ses différentes
composantes je rappelle que l'ifco que
vous connaissez bien institut français
du cheval et de l'équitation dispose par
exemple aujourd'hui d'un budget de
quasiment 43 millions d'euros au
bénéfice de la filière équine ce qui
témoigne de l'engagement constant et de
la parole de l'État dans ce domaine les
échanges entre le gouvernement et la
filière sont approfondis sont réguliers
et nous souhaitons vraiment qu'il le
demeure pour continuer à accompagner la
filière dans le changement de doctrine
européenne que vous avez souligné
monsieur le sénateur et surtout dans la
valorisation des savoir-faire des
pratiques des activités sportives et
culturelles essentielles sans oublier le
tourisme équestre le tourisme équestre
qui représente en France un million de
pratiquants et qui permet une découverte
inédite de notre patrimoine de nos
régions je vous remercie et à merci on
se tient à votre disposition si vous
souhaitez que nous poursuivions les
échanges monsieur Vogel
les dispositions actuelles sont
insuffisantes car le contexte économique
défavorable mais surtout la distorsion
de concurrence entre pays en matière de
fiscalité de TVA pour la filière équine
provoque l'annulation de certaines
courses en France faute d'un nombre
suffisant de partants et entraîne des
pertes de recettes pour le PMU et donc
pour la filière et pour le budget de
l'État l'application de taux réduites
TVA conforme au caractère agricole de la
filière et donc urgent si nous aurons
notre prochaine séance de questions
d'actualité le mercredi 18 janvier à 15h
mais mes chers collègues avant cette
séance ça c'est pour les sénateurs nous
réaliserons notre photographie officier
qui n'avait plus être prises en 2020 en
raison de la crise sanitaire
et je vous remercie de noter dans vos
agendas d'être présent à 14h20 précises
dans l'hémicycle mercredi prochain me
permet d'insister sur l'horaire parce
qu'a début à côté du début de prise de
vue qui doit être pas dorée il sera plus
possible d'entrer dans l'émission et
pratiquer l'injection de photos à
posteriori n'est pas
la bonne formule je compte donc sur vous
et nous allons nous retrouver tout à
l'heure pour le débat
à partir de 16h35 pour le débat
d'actualité sur la crise du système de
santé merci madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres la
séance est suspendue
[Musique]
et voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité du Sénat au gouvernement et
on va commencer par les réactions à
cette séance je suis avec Bruno
Retailleau le président du groupe les
républicains au Sénat bonjour bonjour et
tous mes vœux à vous auditeurs oui oui
alors on va parler de la réforme des
retraites c'était un sujet de cette
après-midi après la présentation hier de
la réforme les républicains sont
favorables et ce qu'on peut dire que les
LR sont dans la majorité d'Emmanuel
Macron autour de cette réforme
vous êtes ici journaliste à Public Sénat
donc vous savez par cœur parfaitement ce
que c'est cette réforme cette réforme
c'est notre réforme donc en réalité
c'est pas nous qui allons voter la
réforme si on la vote du gouvernement
c'est le gouvernement de madame
élysibadborn qui propose à sa propre
majorité de voter la réforme que nous
avons ici en réalité rédigé puis voté
depuis au moins quatre ans alors sur les
grandes lignes vous êtes plutôt
favorables mais quand même quels seront
vos exigences est-ce que le compte y est
totalement dans ce cas présenté la
première ministre alors l'architecture
vient de ce que nous avons conçu ici 64
ans l'accélération pour les annuité de
la réforme dite Touraine mais quand même
67 ans étant le plafond pour que la
décote soit annulée pour ceux et celles
qui n'ont pas la totalité justement de
leurs invités en revanche une réforme
des retraites c'est quelque chose de
lourd de technique et souvent le diable
est dans les détails et donc on va
porter notre attention pour d'abord
vérifier ce qu'a dit madame la Première
ministre si c'est bien appliqué si c'est
bien réel si elle va toucher beaucoup de
Français on va porter notre attention
surtout un sur les petites retraites les
petites retraites effectivement de ceux
qui vont la prendre cette retraite dans
les mois prochains bien sûr ça c'est à
peu près acté mais rien n'a été dit rien
n'est confirmé sur les petites retraites
de celles et ceux qui sont déjà à la
retraite ils sont un million 8 donc là
il y a un point d'éclaircissement de
même pour les femmes il y a cette idée
de valoriser par exemple les congés
parentaux pour les maires de famille
vous savez que quand on parle de petites
retraites les trois quarts des petites
retraites en réalité ce sont des femmes
ce sont des mères de famille parce que
elles ont eu des carrières incomplètes
des temps partiels etc donc voyez c'est
sur des points très précis qu'on va être
très exigeant mais sur la retraite
minimale les 80-5% du SMIC on a entendu
le gouvernement cet après-midi assurer
que ce serait aussi pour les retraités
actuels donc ça vous rassure non
désir la première ministre a indiqué que
ça sera pour les futurs retraités cet
après-midi elle n'a pas encore pris
d'engagement pour le 1 million 800000
retraités qui touchent des toutes
petites retraites pour l'instant le
mécanisme de revalorisation ça n'est pas
du tout acté le budget qui pourrait y
être consacré ça n'est pas du tout acté
or c'est pour nous une sorte de ligne
rouge comme vous n'avez garanti est-ce
que vous vous attacherez vous les
sénateurs de la républicains à une
clause de revoyure sur l'âge de départ
en 2027 qui sera aux alentours de 63 ans
en tout cas pour ce qui me concerne moi
je pense que le cheminement qui consiste
à dire alors 2027 fin du mandat 63 ans
et 3 mois et 2030
c'est un RIB qui me paraît bon voilà
trajectoire que vous validez du côté
d'Aurélien Pradier chez les républicains
il y a une inquiétude qui le pointe
c'est concernant les carrières longues
alors les dispositifs carrière longue
sont maintenus mais avec des effets de
seuil certaines personnes qui ont
commencé très tôt avant 20 ans vont
devoir cotiser 404 ans est-ce que cela
est bien ça peut être remédier pendant
pendant le débat écoutez j'ai entendu il
y a quelques mois Aurélien Pradier
prenait une réforme qui serait plutôt
par les durées de cotisation à 45 à
nuités donc ce que nous dit la première
ministre pour l'instant c'est que dans
sa réforme personne
ira au-delà de 44 à nuités je pense que
pour ce que j'en ai entendu le mécanisme
carrière longue a été amélioré puisque
il y a une marche supplémentaire qui a
été créée il y a moins de 16 ans 16-18
ans et 18 20 ans donc je pense que de ce
point de vue là c'est pas ce qui me
paraît le plus important les deux points
les plus importants à mon sens ce sont
les carrières des maires de familles des
femmes notamment il faut pas que
celle-ci fassent les frais de la réforme
et puis les toutes petites retraites de
ceux et celles qui sont déjà d'ailleurs
à la retraite voilà on a vu favorable il
y avait quand même des lignes rouges et
ça c'est le débat parlementaire on sera
exigeant tout est améliorable comme
c'est quelqu'un merci beaucoup à Bruno
Retailleau d'être venu au micro de
publicaina merci merci beaucoup
Alexandre Bruno Retailleau que l'on sent
donc défendre la réforme des retraites
autre réactions après cette séance de
questions au Gouvernement celle de la
ministre de la transition énergétique
Agnès panier renacher elle est à présent
à votre micro Alexandre mais oui dans
cette séance il a été question de la
réforme des retraites mais aussi de la
crise de l'énergie de la hausse des
factures énergétiques pour les
entreprises pour les très petites
entreprises alors le gouvernement a
obtenu un accord de plafonnement du prix
de l'électricité